working for the SCP Foundation can be a
frightening Endeavor but not all the
anomalies they encounter are violent
vicious monsters all intent on
destruction scps can often be as lost
lonely and sad as the rest of us
sometimes feel in that Spirit let's take
a heartbreaking and tear-jerking journey
through some of the saddest scps that
might even make you cry get those
tissues ready and don't say we didn't
warn you to the untrained Observer
scp-348 is just an ordinary white bowl
with blue flower patterns painted on its
ceramic surface the Chinese lettering on
its side translates to the phrase
thinking of you however if anyone
suffering from a minor injury like a
scraped knee a cut or a bruise or any
other mild ailment is presented with a
bowl its anomalous properties will begin
to show
scp-348 will fill itself with soup
usually varying in ingredients but
consistently enjoyed by those that have
eaten from it finishing the soup though
that's what can start the Waterworks
after someone consumes the contents of
scp-348 a message will appear within the
bowl seemingly coming from the subject's
own father in one such instance a young
boy of six who had been recently injured
whilst playing with his friends was
given scp-348 to eat from the boy's
parents were divorced and his father no
longer lived at home when the child ate
the soup the message in the bowl read
I'm sorry son another similar test was
run by the foundation using scp-348 this
time with an older boy of 11 years old
who was suffering from a cold he had
also been adopted by a foster family
prior the message that appeared after
he'd eaten it said I'm glad you're happy
when testing the effects of scp-348 on
adults less of them felt inclined to
finish the soup in the bowl one of these
much older subjects a 43 year old woman
with a sore throat had become estranged
from her parents after moving away from
home however she would frequently send
them money and eventually help arrange
senior housing for her parents until her
father passed away while she initially
remarked that her soup tasted bitter it
was fulfilling by the end of the meal
the note left by scp-348 simply said
thank you once a test was conducted
involving scp-348 and the 60 year old
man who was suffering from a terminal
illness the grandfather to many
grandchildren was offered the bowl of
soup and delightedly ate it claiming it
was the best soup he had ever tasted it
gave him a sense of satisfaction and
even eased some of the pain caused by
his illness a week later The Old Man
passed away peacefully in his sleep oh
what's that those sweet soup messages
weren't wholesome enough to encourage
even a few sobs okay then you heartless
little monster we'll step up our game
with scp-3017 now you might be forgiven
for thinking that this is a particular
literally monstrous SCP after all that
is his anomalous effect Fraser melbrook
is or rather was an otherwise ordinary
man Afflicted with an infectious Cognito
Hazard this would alter the perception
of anyone around Frasier or any person
who might have spoken to him and made
them believe that he belonged in custody
people would be compelled to think that
Frasier was a dangerous violent
individual but with no actual proof that
he was in many cases anyone exposed to
his Cognito Hazard would even try to
lock him up themselves the one reprieve
however was that a number of Frazier's
immediate family and close friends were
immune to this effect either this was
through experiencing prolonged exposure
to scp-3017 or by simply knowing him
well enough to have context that
canceled out the false beliefs that he
was a violent criminal with an extensive
record designated as
scp-3017-1s the people closest to him
remain unaffected Fraser was able to
maintain healthy relationships with all
of them until scp-3017 fell into the
hands of the foundation arrested and
placed in containment thanks to the
anomalous effects of scp-3017 the
foundation believed that Fraser Mel
Brook had close ties and connections to
multiple groups of Interest they began
to relentlessly torturously interrogate
Frasier threatening his family unless he
gave them the answers to their questions
information that he simply could not
provide he hadn't even heard of the
geois the foundation wanted to know
about let alone had any direct
affiliation with them but still they
kept pressing him keeping him locked up
and not allowing him to see his family
even when his grandmother developed lung
cancer treated with suspicion and
hostility non-stop every day
scp-3017 would get one last shot at
freedom however researcher Rylan who had
been studying Frazier's anomalous
properties as well as a security officer
that had been a signed to watch melbrook
both developed the same immunity to the
prisoner's Cognito Hazard as his family
and friends had working together they
were able to Spring scp-3017 from
Foundation custody and Rylan took him
back home to see his family little did
either of them know of the tragedy that
awaited them in a cruel twist of fate a
house fire had set melbrook's family
home Ablaze claiming the lives of his
parents both brothers his sister
grandmother and even his fiancee utterly
devastated and overwhelmed with grief
the loss of his loved ones completely
broke Frazier he had spent so much of
his life persecuted accused of heinous
crimes and arrested despite being
completely innocent and as if that
wasn't bad enough he'd fought his way
free from the foundation only to find
his home reduced to Ash the day before
he made it back by the time the SCP
Foundation arrived to recapture him it
was already too late Frasier was dead
and researcher Ryland turned herself
over without resistance the foundation
soon realized what they had done how
they had tortured an innocent man who
didn't actually have the information
they thought he did in quiet shame they
reclassified scp-3017 under a new object
class neutralized feeling tyria maybe a
little moist around the eyes oh those
are just your allergies oh yeah of
course they are how could we be so silly
alright let's move on taking a step back
from Grim dark reality for a moment
let's instead delve into a world of
fantasy
scp-1762 was a seemingly ordinary
cardboard box spray painted silver with
the words here be dragons written on it
in permanent marker usually it remained
empty but would occasionally open
releasing dozens of tiny origami dragons
that would fly out after black smoke had
plumed out of the box it was no doubt a
sight to behold the kind of Fantastical
occurrence that is inherently filled
with childlike wonder often a written or
carved message would be left behind
after the origami dragons flew back into
their box and this is how the foundation
was able to learn of the terrible
misfortune known as the Jabberwocky
event the Paper Dragons existed in a
world of fantasy all contained within
the cardboard box when they first
emerged the message they left greeted
someone who had seemingly created the
box and its Fantastical contents or had
at least interacted with it before
possibly a particularly imaginative
child with the reality bending
capability to give life to the inanimate
Paper Dragons the origami creatures
seemed to mistake the foundation for
this original child rediscovering them
after an extended period of time they
made mention of the existence of other
mystical beings in their world including
Giants elves centaurs and more through
their subsequent messages it appeared
something about the world of
scp-1762 was gradually becoming unstable
though it required imagination to
sustain it to stabilize the fantasy
within the box but unfortunately the
foundation Personnel examining
scp-1762 refused to accept the existence
of this world they instead leaned on
science cold hard facts not The Whimsy
of the imaginary when opening the box
all they saw was its empty interior so
to them the fantasy wasn't real it was
the SCP foundation's own lack of belief
their refusal to make believe that was
gradually killing the world inside
scp-1762 through their notes still
unaware that they weren't speaking with
their child Creator the origami dragons
pleaded for Aid cries that fell on the
foundation's deaf ears within the Box
some magical war broke out between the
various creatures inside with the
survivors fleeing for their lives the
Box itself was effectively a portal
linking reality with this realm of
fantasy it existed in a time when the
myths and legends of old were
indeterminable
scp-1762 had once represented a physical
Bond a relationship between those two
worlds But as time had moved on belief
in legends in fantasy had all but
dwindled as the world inside the Box
fell into chaos becoming more and more
unstable the words hereby Dragons Were
burned away from the cardboard surface
in their final message the dragons
mentioned they hoped to escape to a new
world concluding with we are sad we love
you we will not forget you we are scared
will you forget us soon after the Box
returned to its original state with the
phrase here were dragons on the side
marking the end of the Jabberwocky event
and potentially the fantasy within
scp-1762 forever from mystical magical
tales of sadness we now turn to a sad
story from within the ranks of the
foundation itself as CP 451 formerly a
field agent working in the foundation
seems to an outside Observer to be
little more than an average man in his
30s while as average as someone working
for the foundation can be but let's turn
things around if we weren't to Look From
scp-451's perspective how would he see
us that's just the thing he wouldn't he
can't see us or anyone else for that
matter you see for a time this agent was
declared missing in action by the SCP
Foundation the last recorded assignment
he was sent on was an attempt to
retrieve a dangerous anomalous artifact
however this attempt ultimately failed
and scp-451 resurfaced a month later at
site 19. although from his point of view
the entire Foundation facility was empty
he was the last man on Earth or so he
thought at least some unknown influence
had permanently altered the agent's
perception he had been rendered
incapable of perceiving other human
beings now if you're a bit of a Hermit
who prefers their own company then this
might initially sound like like heaven
never having to experience another
awkward interaction with another person
like when you're walking down the street
and someone walking towards you and you
have to try to figure out which way
they're going so you can step in the
opposite direction and avoid bumping
into them then you inevitably do that
weird Shuffle when you both go to walk
the same way you know it's a whole thing
well as good as that might sound to be
rid of happenings like that imagine if
you couldn't see or hear anyone any
attempts the rest of the world made to
communicate with you not one of them
registering but it was somehow worse
than that thanks to his Newfound
surroundings or lack thereof
scp-451 believe that by interacting with
the anomalous artifact he had
single-handedly wiped out the entire
human race the guilt of that action
although only true from his perspective
weighed heavily on scp-451's conscience
he spent a lot of time wandering the
corridors of site 19 overwhelmed by his
apparent isolation eventually the
loneliness of his Newfound condition
coupled with the fallacious knowledge
that he had killed the entire human race
drove him to a state of near Madness but
there would be no escape from this new
state of Perpetual hell not only did the
condition appear to be incurable at
least from what he was capable of doing
but he would not even find solace in
death he had been cursed with some kind
of sadistic immortality and it seemed
like the only way to ever connect with
others was when they themselves were
near death as for what the foundation
were doing to help as CP 451 well
nothing there's little that can do to
reverse the change he was a valuable
field agent to them before it happened
and it's their hope that he can be again
if the process is somehow reversed until
then as CP 451 is forced to live out
this painful existence spending every
day as far as he can tell alone of
course if scp-451 could wish for
anything in his predicament it might be
something as simple as some company if
only there was an SCP that granted the
user their ultimate wish fulfilled any
Fantasy Made Them the hero of Their Own
Story while that happens to be the
function of scp-1230 it appears as a
green hardcover book with no discernible
labels on the spine nor on either front
or back covers the pages are almost
entirely blank save for one simple
phrase on the first one a hero is born
anyone that reads the pages of scp-1230
won't experience any effects immediately
in fact its anomalous properties don't
become apparent until the reader falls
asleep when they do they will experience
a vivid dream that can last anywhere
from 45 seconds to well let's just say
considerably longer although the reader
will never be asleep for any longer than
they normally would be in their dream
the reader will be the protagonist
within their own fantasy world the
entire time they remain fully aware of
their surroundings their senses and
faculties all work as they would as if
they were awake not unlike the fantasy
world of
scp-1762 the dream world's experience by
test subjects who read scp-1230 very
differently on the imagination of the
dreamer additionally once they re-emerge
from their Slumber they will be able to
recall all the events of the dream down
to every Last Detail every dream induced
by reading scp-1230 will also feature a
character known only as the bookkeeper a
friendly bearded old man in a green
cloak who is apparently the
personification of the book itself the
role of the bookkeeper seems to create
the fantasy Scapes as he calls them and
seemingly creates these bespoke worlds
on behalf of all the dreamers he
Encounters in accordance with their own
deepest desires and wants by now you're
no doubt thinking how could this
possibly be a sad SCP I bet you probably
even want to go with scp-1230 yourself
don't you and who wouldn't after all you
would get to be placed in a fantasy
Escape where you can do anything and
every everything you can think of on top
of that this isn't Inception dying or
being harmed in one of these dreams
doesn't translate to real world death
well not directly anyway remember when
we mention the dreams can last a
considerably long time at least in their
own internal fantasy Escape time well
here's what makes it one of the saddest
scps on this list maybe even ever
imagine getting to live out a fantasy
Adventure as the hero the main
protagonist in your own story picture
you spent a number of years in that
dream time experiencing every event of
that story that world first hand it
looks real it feels real for the time
that you're there at least so what
happens when you wake up how are you
going to feel if you're all of a sudden
pulled out of that fantasy and dropped
back into the mundanity of real life
would you prefer your fantasy to the
real world and what would you do if you
couldn't go back that was experience
firsthand by one of the foundation's
researchers known only as professor
he had specifically requested the
foundation to allow him to read scp-1230
and was giddy with excitement when it
came to be his turn like many others he
read the first page seeing a hero is
born and then instantly went to sleep
unwilling to wait until later clearly
eager to experience his very own fantasy
Escape Professor B was asleep for the
next 24 hours before the foundation
security Personnel were forced to
attempt to wake him up when he did he
looked around confused to be
unceremoniously returned to real life it
was almost as if the amount of time he
had spent within the bookkeeper's dream
world had caused him to momentarily
forget his old life with the foundation
however he soon regained his memory
after a brief reminder from fellow staff
but it was never the same after that
Professor B had experienced the life he
had always dreamed of within his dreams
and upon waking he had been returned to
a life where he was an aging tired man
and a dead-end job at the foundation he
was no hero here he was just another
nobody and the sadness was too much for
him professor B passed away not long
after after this tragedy the bookkeeper
was utterly distraught through the
medium of the book he left a note for
the Personnel of the SCP Foundation it
read I'm so sorry I never intended for
this to happen I just wanted to make
people happy a number of weeks passed
before the foundation was able to make
contact with the bookkeeper again
leaving a note that requested a
conversation with the entity a
foundation doctor experienced a dream
that was set in a Dark featureless Void
there he encountered the bookkeeper
crying to himself when questioned about
what had happened to Professor B the
embodiment of scp-1230 explained he had
such an active imagination I was able to
create a vast and beautiful Universe for
him and it was obvious that he wanted a
life like that for so long he conquered
foul beasts and rescued princesses they
built kingdoms and even raised a family
but he never wanted to
he delved so far into his fantasy world
that I soon realized he preferred his
dream over the real world I reminded him
that this was all merely an illusion but
he wouldn't listen to me I tried to keep
him happy for as long as I could
remember when we mentioned the dreams
can last a considerably long time at
least in their own internal fantasy
Escape time Professor B had been living
out his Ultimate Fantasy adventure for
200 years while only a full day's worth
of time had passed in the real world
having to live through all that only to
wake up and realize none of it was real
was perhaps too existentially
overwhelming for the professor then
again maybe he just preferred the world
of his fantasy Escape much more than the
world around him that brings us to one
of the most infamous anomalies in the
foundation's extensive history
scp-096 better known as the shy guy is a
terrifying towering creature with a
hairless body sunken eyes and a huge
gaping mouth but don't you ever get the
sense that there's something inherently
sad about
scp-096 insecurity is something a lot of
us experience and have to face every day
but the shy guys is taken to such an
extreme degree he can't bear the thought
of anyone looking at him it's so bad for
him that it causes him to experience so
much distress that he has to travel
lightning fast to anyone that looks at
his face and once he's caught up with
them and killed them then he's right
back to his usual routine sobbing and
weeping or pacing around his cell
perhaps his story isn't as sad as some
of the others on this list but we do
know it'd be a welcome change if someone
could make the shy guy smile just for a
little while now go check out 25 most
frightening scps and what is the
scariest SCP if you'd like to replace
that sadness with some good
old-fashioned fear